anaïs pronovost morgan gère l'organisme
dignité mensuel leur mission s'attaquer
à la précarité et l'éducation menstruel
la précarité menstruel c'est un problème
double ses poches de sang c'est pas
juste un enjeu de d'avoir les produits
disponibles et accessibles c'est aussi
d'offrir une éducation danse truelle qui
est souvent manquantes puis qui
contribuent à la honte menstruel elle
croit que si tout le monde comprenait
les défis auxquels font face certaines
femmes elles seraient moins stigmatisés
si à cabo et de travail raconte dans
leur sac à dos une pastilla c'est en
général un travail en espagne on veut
s'attaquer à ce problème le gouvernement
vient de déposer un avant projet de loi
qui comprend un congé de maladie payés
pour les douleurs menstruelles
invalidante supprimer le pays se
développe à un drôle a repris mais là on
a une capacité morale paris intra muros
et incapacitantes est fixée comme aussi
anaïs trouve l'idée excellente surtout
pour assurer l'équité entre les
personnes qui monstrueux et les autres
mais croit que l'instauration de ce
genre de mesures doit venir avec un
suivi rigoureux l'important lexsi mesure
le sait que on les instants
qu'ensuite qu'on étudie ses impacts pour
qu'on puisse ajuster le tir selon selon
selon les problèmes qui en ressortent
selon la docteure diane francoeur c'est
aussi une excellente nouvelle car
beaucoup de femmes sont touchées aller
jusqu'à 20% de la population sont
vraiment très très très incapacité et
c'est clair qu'on peut pas travailler
quand on souffre comme ça il c'est clair
qu'on ne devrait pas travailler non plus
lorsqu'on est on est aussi souffrent des
mesures similaires existent déjà dans
certains pays d'asie comme le japon la
corée du sud ou l'indonésie mais
attention disent certains ces mesures
peuvent mener la discrimination des
femmes al embauche et au cours de leur
carrière ici et lisez céret radio canada
montréal